scp-682 versus scp-1056  could this anomalous body-warping  kitchen timer finally be the thing that  shrinks scp-682 down to size let's find  out the objective of the test was to see  how long it would take scp-682 to return  to its normal size after being resized  by scp-1056  however when the creature was meant to  be shrunk to a quarter of its size it  simply disappeared it was later found  causing chaos outside of site-19 having  returned to its normal size when a  mobile task force was sent to apprehend  682 it released a wave that instead  massively shrunk the task force it  continued to rampage elsewhere  manipulating its size at will until a  combined group of mobile task forces  were able to incapacitate it researchers  concluded that it had not only absorbed  the anomalous effects of scp-1056  but enhanced it leading to considerably  more powerful defensive and offensive  body resizing capabilities